ماجن ماركل لا تاكل كثيرا وتصنع ملابسها
بنفسها ووالدي يغار منها تصريحاتهن للامير
هاري تحمل نظرا انتقادات جديده للعائله
الملكه فبعد ايام من طرح مذكرات الامير
للبيع قبل الموعد الرسمي لنشرها وما
تضمنته من مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف والشقاق
داخل العائله الملكيه البريطانيه كتابه
هاري الذي طرح للبيع في اسبانيا قبل خمسه
ايام من موعد اصداره الرسمي احتل المرتبه
الاولى على قائمه الكتب الاكثر مبيعا على
موقع امازون في بريطانيا رغم ان استطلاعات
الراي اشعارات الى ان الكثير من
البريطانيين ضاقوا ذرعا بميلا دراما
العائله المالكه برمتها وان الكشف عن مزيد
من المفاجات لن يغير ارائها هؤلاء سواء
المتعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته مجد ماركل او
تلك المنتقده لهم ولكن بالنسبه لها
الالتزام لن يجعل الامور افضل وفق ما
اعلنه في مقابلاته مع اي تي في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
واوفقا لدوق وهو الامير هاري فان والده
بان زوجته
في اليوم الذي ماتت فيه الملكه اليزابيث
كما انه رفض سابقا انتقال مع كل العيش
معهم وفقا لمذكرات الامير طبعا والذي قال
اي الامير هاري انه يفكر بسخريه
بانها بان تكلفه ماركل لتوفير الطعام
والماوى كانت ضئيل بالنظر الى انها لا
تتمتع بشهيه كبيره ويمكنها صناعه ملابسها
الخاصه كتاب ادخل العائله الملكيه في اكبر
ازماتها منذ مسلسل عرض في التسعينيات
وتناول انهيار زواج من الاميره الراحله
ديانا والدته ويلي الكتاب لم تعلق عليه
حتى الساعه العائله الملكيه والذي جاء بعد
اربعه اشهر فقط من وفاه الملكه اليزابيث
وتوليد تشارلز للعرش
ولا احد يعرف اين كانوا او ما كانوا
يفعلونه ليله وفاه والدتي بكيت مره واحده
اثناء مراسم الدفن ولا حاجه لخوض في مدى
غرابه الامر او الذنب الذي شعرت به انا
وويليام ايضا الجميع كانوا يعتقدون
ويشعرون بانهم يعرفون امي واقربوا شخصين
منها واكثر شخصين احبتهما لم يتمكن من
التعبير عن اي مشاعره في تلك اللحظه
[موسيقى]